no one can deny the impact the X Files
had on the Sci-Fi genre and television
as a whole yeah that's a bleeping dead
alien body if I ever bleep in saw one
the xfiles was a huge series throughout
its run and it had other networks as
well as Fox itself trying to replicate
the show's success NBC took a crack at
it with dark skies which was dismissed
by some critics as a mere clone of the X
Files due to just how similar the two
series were on the other side of the
coin there are some particularly in
retrospect who have made the case that
dark Skies is actually the superior of
the two shows ultimately Dark Skies
didn't have the ratings to Grant it more
than 20 episodes causing it to suffer
the same fate as most xfiles inspired
shows but it was arguably the best with
a unique premise that saw it taking
place in an alternate history 1960s in
which aliens had been on Earth since
the' 40s with the government having kept
their existence a secret from the public
it also didn't shy away from depicting
real people including politicians actors
musicians and more